pour les voyageurs américains ayant reçu
deux doses de vaccin
les restrictions de déplacements
devraient être levés au début du mois de
mai selon emmanuel macron qui a affirmé
travailler avec la maison blanche à
l'allemagne rend hommage à ces
quatre-vingt mille morts c'était ce
matin il y avait une messe à la mémoire
des personnes décédées les coronavirus
une cérémonie religieuse à berlin en
présence de la chancelière angela merkel
et du chef de l'état allemand frank
walter steinmeier
un hommage qui intervient en pleine
polémique sur les restrictions dans le
pays
le gouvernement souhaite imposer de
nouvelles mesures dont un couvre-feu ce
que les länder les états régions voient
d'un mauvais oeil et en italie on se
prépare à la saison touristique avec ce
train qu'ovide free à une ligne à grande
vitesse ont toutes les personnes à bord
sont négatives au courant d'un virus
peut-être un exemple à suivre
on voit cela avec médias ce qui fit un
test avant de monter à bord du tgv
c'est le concept lancé en italie sur la
ligne rome milan intitulé kobe de free
il consiste à tester tout le personnel
de bord et les voyageurs avant d'entrer
dans le wagon même les personnes
vaccinées
les italiens se montre plutôt séduits
par le procédé
même pendant la période du coc vide
j'ai continué à voyager parce que je
pouvais le faire en toute sécurité
j'aime ce projet de train qu'ovide free
notamment le fait que le tampon est
gratuit inclus dans le service j'avais
déjà fait un voyage similaire kovy de
free mais en avion avec à l'italien en
juin dernier
avec ce système vous pouvez voyager plus
sereinement
l'alternative est d'aller à rome en
voiture ce qui n'est pas la meilleure
solution
j'ai fait le test ici à la gare une
heure avant le départ du train qui était
fixé à 18 heures c'est une bonne
solution car elle nous permet de voyager
en toute sécurité
en sachant que tous les autres passagers
sont négatifs aux copies de 19
pour voyager à bord conducteurs
contrôleurs et passagers doivent
présenter un test pcr ou antigénique
négatif datant de moins de 48 heures
autrement ils doivent passer par un
stand de la croix rouge juste avant le
départ du train situé aux abords de la
gare
objectif de ce dispositif anti qu'ovide
anticiper la reprise du tourisme dans le
pays
al'approche de la période estivale il
faut pouvoir reprendre notre activité en
regardant vers l'été c'est certain c'est
un jour important
après la messe deux hommes
nous pouvons anticiper l'avenir des
voyages en toute sécurité cet été
en europe l'eurostar impose déjà aux
passagers souhaitant traverser la manche
de présenter un test négatif et des vols
covit free ont été testés entre rome et
milan
ainsi qu'entre la capitale italienne et
les états unis
pour le moment seule la liaison
ferroviaire directe entre rome et milan
et concernés par ce dispositif
d'autres villes du pays pourrait
rapidement suivre si les résultats sont
convaincants
bien entendu le masque est obligatoire
et les trains ne sont remplis qu'à 50%
de bonne augure avant la saison estivale
en 2020 le nombre de touristes en italie
a chuté de plus de 50% par rapport à
ailleurs dans le monde les mesures
antigrippe se renforcer le cas en
thaïlande où les bars les salles de
spectacle et les écoles ferment dès
aujourd'hui pour deux semaines au moins
l'épidémie est à son plus haut niveau
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
les précisions c'est avec un maximum à
berre la thaïlande prend de plein fouet
l'arrivée du variant britannique 18
provinces dans le rouge et près de 1600
nouveaux cas détectés vendredi un record
pour le pays
face à cette hausse inquiétante des
contaminations le premier ministre
thaïlandais a annoncé le durcissement
des mesures anti qu'ovide fermeture
totale des barres des écoles et des
salles de spectacles fermeture après 21h
des restaurants et des centres
commerciaux
confronté à des rassemblements
antigouvernementaux depuis un an le
premier ministre prayut chan o cha a
également appelé les manifestants à
faire preuve de retenue
toutes ces mesures sont mûrement
réfléchies
ces décisions sont douloureuses parce
que je sais qu'il y a des gens qui sont
affectés par cela beaucoup de gens ont
dit qu'il fallait tout fermé mais il
faut penser à la façon dont cela
affectera certaines personnes et prendre
en compte la sécurité des autres mais
tout le monde doit travailler ensemble
cette vague épidémique aurait pour
origine plusieurs soirées organisées
dans des boîtes de nuit à bangkok dans
la capitale désormais certains habitants
craignent même de se rendre dans les
centres de dépistage
le fait de sortir de devoir être aidés
est touché par d'autres personnes
présentent un risque élevé de contracter
le virus selon moi
et quand les gens viennent m'aider je
les remercie de leur bonne intention
mais je ne sais pas quels risques ces
bons samaritains peuvent représenter
je pense que l'épidémie en thaïlande
sera longue car le variant britannique
se propage rapidement
mais les symptômes ne sont peut-être pas
aussi évident que ceux de la souche
original dans ce pays de 67 millions
d'habitants seuls cinq cent mille
personnes ont reçu leurs premières doses
de vaccin soit moins d'un pour cent de
la population
malgré tout la thaïlande entend vacciner
la moitié des adultes d'ici la fin de
l'année
le pays doit s'appuyer notamment sur une
production locale de vaccins astrazeneca
une production qui ne devrait pas
arriver avant juin prochain
et à propos de la situation dans le pays
et coûté à l'impact lé président de
l'association médicale franco asiatique
malgré une économie basée sur le
tourisme en berne il faut des confiant
sur la capacité avec thaïlandais à se
faire vacciner une fois les doses
disponibles à la saison qui est en train
de s'achever est là parce que la saison
d'hiver et la grande saison touristique
a été un désastre pour les hôtels les
restaurants des sites je disais tout à
l'heure six millions de personnes au
chômage total c'est à dire que ils
touchent aucune aide et les hôtels sont
totalement fermés depuis le mois
d'octobre
alors il comptait un peu sur le tourisme
local même éventuellement régionales
mais ça ne marche pas du tout à phuket à
shanghai un tir bas il ya des centres de
vaccination donc ils doivent être en ce
moment alimentés avec du vaccin indien
astrazeneca fabriqués en inde et
prochainement ils vont avoir une usine
de production de vaccin locale en
thaïlande
et dès qu'ils auront suffisamment de
vaccins et pourront l'appliquer sont
très très équipés pour ça est très bien
organisée
les états unis et la chine se disent
prêts à coopérer sur le changement
climatique une déclaration commune de
pékin et washington avant le sommet
virtuel organisé jeudi vendredi prochain
par les états unis 40 dirigeants
mondiaux sont conviés en déplacement à
séoul john kerry et l'émissaire
américain pour le climat en a profité
pour encourager la chine à réduire son
utilisation de charbon ce n'est pas cela
je ne pointe pas du doigt nous nous
avons eu trop de charbon d'autres pays
ont trop de charbon mais la chine est le
plus grand utilisateur de charbon dans
le monde et parce que c'est une économie
un pays si grand et puissant
cela doit changer maintenant certaines
choses ont été faites
la chine a connu un déploiement
incroyable d'énergies renouvelables et
la chine est un important producteur de
panneaux solaires dans le monde
mais cela ne veut pas dire qu'il n'est
pas nécessaire de réduire le charbon
nous devons le faire nous avons eu une
longue discussion à ce sujet justin
trudeau a également réagi le premier
ministre canadien souligne le grand rôle
que les états unis sont amenés à jouer
plusieurs années après leur retrait de
l'accord de paris écouter l'engagement
des états unis
après quelques années loin de la table
des discussions sur le climat est
quelque chose que les gens vont regarder
pour s'assurer qu'ils sont sérieux et
engagé mais il ne fait aucun doute que
nous avons besoin d'un pays de
l'envergure des états unis pour faire
partie de la solution et non du problème
si nous voulons nous en sortir en tant
que planète et on en vient aux tensions
dans le donbass entre l'ukraine et la
russie emmanuel macron s'est exprimé sur
la crise lors d'une interview diffusé
aujourd'hui par la chaîne américaine
si billet s'il estime que les sanctions
contre la russie sont insuffisantes et
il devrait s'entretenir prochainement
avec son homologue russe vladimir
poutine avant de l'écouter on rappelle
que vendredi il a reçu son homologue
asnières volodymyr zelensky à l'elysée
et la tenue avec la chancelière
allemande une visioconférence une
réunion tripartite pour demander à
moscou de retirer ses troupes massées à
la frontière ukrainienne
par ailleurs l'ukraine presse le et
l'otan de l'intégrer on l'est plus
maintenant le président français je
pense qu'après un comportement
inacceptable
effectivement nous devons fonctionner il
dit c'est que nous avons fait après
l'ukraine où après une série de crises
qui se sont produites et je pense que
nous devons définir des lignes rouges
clair avec la russie c'est la seule
façon d'être crédible elle je pense que
les sanctions ne sont pas suffisantes en
soi est en elle-même mais les sanctions
font partie je préfère un dialogue
constructif fait pour avoir un dialogue
constructif et efficace 5
il faut être crédible et de son côté
moscou appelle au respect des accords de
link qui prévoit un cessez le feu dans
le dombass notre envoyé spécial antoine
claireaux et sur place ado n'y est plus
précisément une ville où les combats
font rage depuis le début du conflit et
aujourd'hui seuls quelques habitants y
vivent encore au milieu des décombres
regardez je me trouve maintenant dans le
quartier de l'aéroport de deux nièces
que l'aéroport qui se trouve juste ici
sur ma gauche théâtre des combats parmi
les plus violents les plus sanglants en
particulier au début du conflit je vous
propose d'aller à la rencontre d'un des
derniers habitants de ce quartier qui
continuent de vivre ici et ce malgré les
bombardements quasi quotidiens
il ya des tirs tout le temps tous les
jours ils tirent sur l'aéroport autour
sur spartak le village d'à côté personne
ne vit ici
ma fille m'a dit de déménager dans leur
appartement et je lui ai répondu que je
ne quitterai jamais ma maison je les
construite moi même je ne la quitterai
jamais l'aéroport john yates qui a été
l'objet de batailles féroces entre
soldats ukrainien et combattant du nom
base durant une bonne partie de l'année
2014 en particulier en automne et en
hiver les bâtiments de l'aéroport ont
été réduits à l'état de ruines
tout comme la plupart des habitations
alentour nicolaï qui est en quelque
sorte la mémoire vivante des habitants
de ce quartier nous a raconté ce qu'il
est advenu d'eux
la maison de ses voisins cette maison a
été touchée par deux missiles grad
à l'intérieur ça a pris feu deux
missiles ont explosé
c'est un voisin qui vivait ici mais son
coeur a lâché pendant les bombardements
il est mort il ne reste plus une seule
maison inde m c'est la croix rouge qui a
réparé montois le toit et le plafond
avait été cassée 14 missiles ont
transpercé dans la grange les colombiens
ont été rasés j'ai eu des dents cassées
ce quartier quasiment à l'abandon
maintenant depuis de nombreuses années
reste néanmoins très dangereux en plus
des bombardements quasi quotidiens
il faut sans cesse regarder où l'on met
les pieds de risque de marcher sur une
munition sur une grenade qui n'a pas
encore explosé
autre tension cette fois entre la russie
et la république tchèque à moscou a
vivement réagi à l'expulsion de 18
diplomates russes par prague et hier à
ces derniers sont accusés d'espionnage
aux décisions infondées inventé de
toutes pièces selon la diplomatie russe
la russie qui envisage des mesures de
rétorsion pour bientôt en attendant elle
a convoqué l ambassadeur tchèque sur son
sol ont fait le point en images
[Musique]
on
oui
[Musique]
on
mais
[Musique]
en égypte à un accident de train fait
une centaine de blessés aujourd'hui ça
s'est passé dans la ville de bâle rare
au nord du caire quatre wagons de ce
train de passagers ont déraillé on ne
connaît pas les causes de ce
déraillement une enquête est en cours
cet accident il intervient trois
semaines après la collision entre deux
trains qui avait fait 18 morts dans la
province de soria dans le centre du pays
les troupes armées de l'erythrée vont se
retirer de la région du tigré pour la
première fois le gouvernement érythréen
reconnu la présence de ses troupes dans
cette partie de l'ethiopie et ce dans
une lettre adressée au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu reste une part d'ombré
la victoire elle a été proclamée le 28
novembre et les troupes érythréennes
seraient restés sur place
elles sont accusées d'avoir perpétré des
massacres et des violences sexuelles ce
que nie l'ambassadrice du pays dans sa
lettre aux nations unies chien pour
louis keumayou président du club de
l'information africaine des exactions
bien été commise sur place écouter tout
ce que nous savons pour l'instant c'est
que vos débuts c'était des accusations
qui protège les populations munich re et
l'ouvrir météo piché de l'essai la
semaine était remonté c'est la rentrée
dans le tigré pour se rendre compte de
la situation et non avec le personnel
médical et une documentation
relativement précis des exactions
commises par les sondeurs c'est ainsi
qu'on a pu mais qui a eu énormément de
l'homme qui auraient été commis est-ce
que c'est uniquement la médée gear qui
l'a fait roi le break ce que c'est
l'armée éthiopienne kg m2 comparé ces
exactions là il est pour l'instant
difficile de dire à une précision
une chose est sûre c'est que bien des
exactions qui ont été promis via des
personnes et des victimes de ces
exactions et on attend de voir ce que le
mode raid à bord produits
les éventuelles enquêtes qui pourront
suivre pour déterminer les
responsabilités
on attend que 16 ans et enfin retour en
france la loi anti gaspillage dans le
collimateur des producteurs de fruits et
légumes a notamment la partie sur la
suppression progressive des emballages
plastiques
il estime ne pas avoir assez de temps
pour s'adapter à la nouvelle
réglementation conséquence une perte
sèche à un manque à gagner pourrait être
très important aux reportages dans le
tarn et garonne avec valentin carpentier
hervé grandchamp l'époque des emballages
plastiques sur les fruits et légumes
bientôt révolu promulguée le 10 février
2020 la loi anti gaspillage sera
effective le 1er janvier 2022 et va
changer beaucoup de choses notamment
pour les producteurs visant à supprimer
l'ensemble des plastiques de notre
quotidien
la loi s'attaque principalement aux
emballages des fruits et légumes vendus
en grande surface à moissac dans le tarn
et garonne
la nouvelle loi rend furieux d'autant
plus qu'aucun producteur n'a été
consulté nous avons été au pied du mur
ou une ministre a pris une décision un
jour sans consultation et sans nous
donner le temps de l'adaptation est
aujourd'hui il va y avoir des
conséquences importantes dans notre
filière et sans avoir aussi tenu compte
que ça fait cinq six ans qu'on est déjà
sur le sujet où dès qu'on a pu sortir le
plastique des emballages nous l'avons
fait et sur les petits emballages c'est
un peu plus dur un peu plus long un
changement conséquent pour les
producteurs car c'est tout un système de
production qui va devoir être modifiés
l'ensemble des lignes de production et
d'emballage va même devenir désuet
alors que les grandes surfaces refuse le
vrac des options déjà été réfléchi comme
la barquette en carton les producteurs
regrette toutefois le manque de temps
pour s'adapter et s'alarme sur le futur
manque à gagner le problème d'une loi
c'est que quand ça va trop vite et qu'on
n'a pas le temps
ici on ne sait pas comment va être la
réaction du consommateur
il va voir beaucoup moins le free est ce
que il va être attiré par la barquette
comment on fait pour eux
pour que vraiment on est là
même chose que sur l'ancien il nous faut
du temps et c'est ce temps là qui nous a
été refusé par cette loi hajek
il reste donc moins d'un an aux
coopératives agricoles pour trouver une
solution
un emballage valorisant le produit et le
laissant visibles un défi de taille pour
les producteurs et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
va se retrouver dans 30 minutes à rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il
mise en lumière lippert mondialisation
et les contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes passions de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser et bien
il faut déjà empêché les ca vaut de
partir ou en tous cas lors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ait des candidats n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des souligné rob uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes commencent